alright so the big news in the media
world especially about the media world
is that Jon Stewart announced last night
that he is leaving The Daily Show in a
couple months people are going crazy he
is the most trusted name in news that's
what they tell you I guess that's kind
of ironic that a comedian would be the
most trusted name in news but you know
if you want to be told the truth
generally it's served best when
someone's being funny otherwise you get
punched in the face somebody said that I
forget who anyway Jon Stewart's leaving
and then of course yesterday also Brian
Williams NBC News announced that they're
going to put him on a leave of absence
for six months he will not get paid five
million dollars makes ten million
dollars a year that's more than I make
anyway I thought to think maybe just
switch jobs John could do the real news
on NBC and Brian Williams could just
make up fake news on Comedy Central but
apparently that's not what's going to
happen anyway I was an intern at the
Daily Show in 1999 just when John had
taken over the daily show from craig
kilborn and i was just starting to do
stand-up and i had a couple interactions
with john which were always for me they
were always great because this is a guy
who I wanted to get where he was and he
was barely even a sliver of who he is
now at the sort of icon that he is now
anyway I asked him once we were at a
party like a holiday party or something
I asked him if you could just give me
any advice as a stand-up if he could
just tell me anything and he immediately
without even flinching he goes two words
don't stop and I've always taken that
with me that you can't stop if you have
a mission if you've got something to do
for me comedy trying to tell the truth
and and bringing it in an entertaining
way that you just got to keep doing it
and it's for all the nights that I stood
outside in Times Square handing out
tickets in the rain and the sleet in the
snow to just so I could perform for a
couple minutes and all the shitty road
gigs and all the the TV things that I
almost got that didn't get and
everything else but you just can't stop
and don't stop and I think that
transcends certainly beyond just this
this little thing that I do in 2 i'm
sure that's a piece of advice that we
could all take anyway i just want to put
it out there that I've been sitting at a
desk speak in my mind telling truth to
power fighting the nonsensical media all
the things that John's all that I've
been doing that for quite some time now
on the YouTube here you guys have
hopefully been enjoying what I do so I
just want to put it out there but i'll
i'll consider the gig Comedy Central if
you are looking for some
buddy that will keep this machine going
and do it the right way I'm putting it
out there dave rubin for the Daily Show
let's do it people